yes
dear colleagues
good morning this
morning we have with us today the prime
minister of Luxembourg Mr Xavier bettel
prime minister Diego welcome to the
European Parliament and thank you for
accepting our invitation to be part of
our this is Europe series of debates
I take this opportunity to thank you and
the people of Luxembourg for your belief
steadfast belief in Europe and your
resounding commitment to our shared
values for your leadership in pushing
our project forward and for showing that
the limitations of geography are no
limits to the potential of a people we
will not forget your unwavering support
for Ukraine for welcoming displaced
ukrainians in your homes in your schools
and communes and for earmarking almost
one-fifth of your defense budget to help
Ukraine defend itself against the
Russian invasion allow me to praise you
prime minister for your strong position
on holding perpetrators of war crimes to
Justice the European Parliament will
always push for peace a real peace with
the justice and accountability and we
know that for there to be a peace there
must be a Ukraine as your government
said in a statement earlier this year
Luxembourg will never resign itself to a
world in which force prevails Over Law
and that is why we have also been able
to count on Luxembourg to show Firm
support for Ukraine on its path to EU
membership for this prime minister and
for so much more I would like to thank
you and assure you that this Parliament
will continue to stand for these causes
and for our common values with
Luxembourg and with you
you have the floor
um
Madam president
dear members of the European Parliament
what a privilege it is to be with you
again in this assembly and I'm extremely
grateful to the president for having
invited me and I uh salute the
presence of the commissioner as well
for me this is the this house is the
epicenter of European democracy and uh
70 years my country has hosted the this
institution Secretariat
back in 2018
when I addressed the house there were
some existential doubts
in the European Union to do with
the Euro crisis the migration pressure
in 2015 and this had divided the member
states and divided this house
in 2016 there was the referendum in the
UK and a number of member states saw a
rise in nationalism and identity
movements and there was talk of the end
of the Union there was talk of various
member states leaving and the fact that
there was nothing that we could do
about it
and now in 2023 it's a pleasure to see
that all that has not happened
in the last five years
we have seen deeper crises than that of
and we have risen to the challenge
including Madam president your own
Institution
we have shown solidarity with Ireland
following brexit we've preserved the
Integrity of the internal Market
after some initial hiccups with covid we
have managed to guarantee the free
movement of people and goods and
we worked hard to eliminate the damage
Luxembourg is a country where we cannot
close the borders because if we did we
wouldn't have anyone working in the
hospitals
we have 200 000 cross-border workers
it's Unthinkable to close the borders
and it's Daft to think that you can stop
a virus by closing borders
imagine if whatever happened with uh
with the individual contracts imagine if
we had left vaccines a vaccine
procurement to the free market
Luxembourg wouldn't have been able to
afford them and it's thanks to the
commission it's thanks to the common uh
Collective purchasing that it didn't
matter whether you were a Luxembourg a
Maltese or or whoever you were able to
have access to the vaccine it's very
easy to forget all that
foreign
we also have common debt uh issuance
through next Generation EU
and without this house we wouldn't have
a conditionality uh mechanism
on respect for the rule of law
and then support for Ukraine the
provision of humanitarian and Military
assistance and the reception of uh
refugees in Europe has made us a
credible geopolitical player
and then of course the climate crisis
which should not be overlooked and the
energy crisis we've managed to reduce
our consumption and we are moving
towards uh
Renewables
over fossil fuels
this is all about the
Legacy that we are going to leave to our
children
if we want future generations to enjoy
our quality of life then these are
choices that we have to make and I I'd
like to salute the leadership of this
house in uh the debate about climate
change you are elected by the citizens
you represent the citizens
and
I have been
presenting the findings of a survey
which has revealed that the citizens
whom we so often think are a bit
skeptical about climate change actually
want to go further than us
these are ideas from the Grassroots to
uh Drive policy why should we why should
we be afraid of the citizens just
because of five-year electoral Cycles
even if
we have to stand for uh election we
should allow the people to speak their
views and I think we'd be surprised
sometimes at the the enthusiasm and the
ideas that can emanate from them
we should not be shy in this respect
I want to emphasize the need to remain
open our Union should remain open to the
world
protectionism is an easy reflex
I want to say something about European
values and fundamental rights
and
the need for our Union to rise to the
challenge presented by the war on our
borders during the
pandemic I said that
we had demonstrated Unity
little Luxembourg took in French
patients during the pandemic thanks to
the cross-border workers we were able
also to bring in patients from France
that's the European Union the European
Union is not about slamming the door and
saying everyone looks after their own we
need common
Solutions we cannot achieve much alone
so it's very important for me to see in
the future
[Music]
I have to say I'm from a generation that
doesn't remember a war
many
many of our electorate remember the Iron
Curtain they remembered division
and do we in the European Union of today
want to send a message that we want more
walls Europe is about bringing down
walls and barriers we shouldn't make the
mistakes of the past Madam president
[Applause]
we also need and
the single Market
56 million jobs have been created
in the European Union thanks to the
single Market according to the European
parliamentary research service
I mean great things have been achieved
in consumer protection and food safety
and
it is the single Market that will enable
us to remain competitive at a global
level
however
the single Market is not enough we need
to be open to the rest of the world in
terms of investment flows
and the EU needs to defend itself
against uh
protectionism and uh
against
um
certain types of investment it's very
important for there to be strategic
autonomy but let me explain what
strategic autonomy is it is not
protectionism
it is not
lifting the drawbridge and it's not
keeping distance from the rest of the
world
we
should
concentrate on outcomes rather than
fanciful debate
The Net Zero industry act that chips Act
and the critical materials act the
commission has done its bit
Luxembourg considers openness as
fundamental to strategic autonomy open
markets a Level Playing Field
and climate and human rights issues will
always be part of our prosperity
protectionism protectionism makes you
poorer
and it also ultimately makes you
dependent on the other hand strategic
autonomy means diversification of Supply
chains it means cooperating with those
who share our values including meeting
the objectives of the Paris Accord
strategic autonomy also means protect
proactive industrial policy in order to
keep Manufacturing in Europe
it is important to secure
the supply of critical raw materials and
to diversify it's important to end
dependence on fossil fuels and to
promote the generation of renewable
energy
hydrogen and so on
technology and Innovation are essential
and hence I talk in terms of open
strategic autonomy
and when I'm talking about openness
ladies and gentlemen I cannot avoid
touching up on the issue of a truly
common European migration policy I agree
that in order to Shang into work we need
to be in a position to better regulate
and control access to the Schengen area
however for me that does not
and can in no way imply that we
Europeans do not have a legal obligation
and a moral duty to offer those who seek
International protection a realistic
possibility to do so and to Grant
International protection to those who
qualify for it
that's a
as I have told my colleagues at the
February European Council Boulder walls
are not only costly and questionable
from a political point of view but they
are not effective in stopping irregular
migration
we have to improve their surveillance of
our external borders and engage with
International Partners on issues like
returns or the management of migratory
flows or addressing the root causes of
irregular migration and setting up
possibilities for a regular migration at
the same time the respect for
fundamental rights as well as
International humanitarian law should be
the guiding principle for common
European migration policy that preserves
and strengthens our credibility with our
neighbors and other third-party
countries the external Dimension can
over only be complementary to the
internal Dimension a common European
migration policy needs to be fair
resilient rules-based and characterized
by the right balance between solidarity
and responsibility for me to European
Asylum and migration pact and the
related Preparatory work by the
successive French Czech and Swedish
presidencies represents the Only
Solution on the table which to put
essential to achieve this balance let us
not give up The Pact and let us try to
hammer out an agreement before the end
of this legislator using the joint
roadmap of the European Parliament and
the council as our Compass to this end
for me one of the central
characteristics of the European project
has been the fact that it's always been
solidly ensured in the respectful
fundamental rights
and rule of law this has been my main
theme of my speech before this plenary
last November and as I told in the press
conference I had a prepared speech about
Technical and secretary etc etc et
cetera but Roberta you showed us the
video
of Simon Way
and this changed my whole speech
for you know who was Simon way but we
are celebrating not celebrating
remembering today you have this yellow
star on you
Simon Way had not only a yellow star or
flower this is
she was marked for life
she was Jewish
she fought
during her political engagement for
Women rights
and for me she represents Europe
this peace project
this project of
respecting people how they are and so
that is the reason I want to excuse
officially to all my team who prepares
usually long speeches and I don't very
often stick to that
but it was for me important to remind
that and for me you have to continue to
fight
for these rights for this rule of law
and for these human rights
defensive the rule of law and Phantom
rights fundamental rights of citizens
has to be the foundation stone of this
European Union we cannot change the
rules according to who is in power
and I want to salute the European
parliament's role in the introduction
of the conditionality clause for
multi-annual financing and Next
Generation EU
for certain National Recovery plans the
funds have been suspended and
and the
uh procedures being taken against the
LGBT plus law in Hungary and there are
15 member states supporting the
commission
and Orban wanted a law which would
prevent people talking about
homosexuality in the media
if there's anyone in this house who
thinks that you become a homosexual by
watching the television or listening to
a song then you've not understood
anything the most difficult for a
homosexual is to accept themselves
[Applause]
nobody's asking for pity or solidarity
or compassion just respect
just respect
there is no point in having a double
life or a secret life do you know how
many young people commit suicide because
they are unable to communicate their
homosexuality it is appalling to
think that you can deal
with this by a law on the media when I
accepted this my family said finally my
friend said finally
but the idea that in another country I
couldn't say this because I could end up
in prison I could
uh
lose my life
the idea that in a European Union member
State I could only talk about this in
secret
I understand that there are people who
want to win votes
at the expense of minorities we've had
that before in our history
Madam president
I think
that we can add some tools to our box in
terms of the rights of minorities
and I will be asking in future for more
solidarity for our to meet our climate
goals industrial policy goals
and Madam president allow me to conclude
by saying something about this war the
Russian aggression against Ukraine
which has been taking place on our
borders for the past year
many people
thought
that the European Union would not be
United and yet it is the European Union
is never strong when it is not United
its member states alone cannot achieve
much but the European Union when it is
United can achieve a great deal
I
don't see an end to this anytime soon
the United Nations Charter is being
violated
Luxembourg as you said Madam president
does not accept impunity
Robert Schumann of Luxembourg in 1950
said that world peace can only be
achieved
by peace efforts commensurate to the
threats we face and it is really up to
us to uh
actor United against Russian aggression
penalize the aggressor
and support Ukraine financially deliver
arms to Ukraine as you said we have
devoted a big chunk of our budget to
Ukraine to
enable it to defend itself
and we need creative efforts in terms of
enlargement
as a geopolitical tool help a Ukraine on
its way to accession
we need to ensure that the European
Union can work as a as a bigger Union in
terms of its budget and finances and we
will need to mobilize the resources to
rebuild Ukraine and to stop for war on
our continent once and for all
we must not disappoint our citizens we
have to ensure that the rule of law is
respected we have to meet our climate
objectives we have to deliver
to Ukraine and we have to complete this
process of building something together
which is going to enable us to achieve
something
uh as I think it was Churchill who said
that uh
alone we can move faster but together we
can move further
and
had it not been for Europe as a prime
minister of Luxembourg I might not be in
a position uh here to address you
and their
those of you uh there are many of you
here who who argue and and fight but you
don't use weapons you use words and
that's how it should be and we certainly
should not fall prey to populism thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister
to the colleagues starting with the
representatives of the political groups
I ask you all to stick to your a lot of
time starting with the Epp group Isabel
vislalima
Mr Prime Minister
thank you prime minister the European
Union and with Luxembourg at its heart
still attracts many many people and this
is one of its strengths but the European
Union is equally at a Crossroads we need
more European in order to be able to
face up to a world which has become
increasingly hostile to democracy and
which has indeed seen the return of War
to our continent thanks to the
autocratic and egg Tendencies of Russia
which has invaded Ukraine we need more
Europe and more autonomy not least
vis-a-vis China
the covet pandemic has
shown the citizens of Europe that what
the European Union can do and there is
now an awareness of the importance of
the health union and I'd like to thank
the prime minister of Luxembourg for
highlighting this the covet has pandemic
also showed us what shortages and supply
chain problems meant in terms of food
medicines or vital technology we can
must no longer depend on other
continents we need to be self-reliant
and we need to be reshoring our
production in Luxembourg too this is the
way we can guarantee our future European
defenses absolutely imperative we need
to have a military which can take
autonomous decisions effectively
we must be aware that dependence in
energy sources economically or
militarily makes us weaker
we must therefore
strengthen the autonomy of decision
making and our autonomy de facto this is
what will provide our strength this will
bring us closer to peace and to having
this strong European Union to which we
all Aspire thank you
I give the floor now to the president of
the snd group Iraqi Garcia Perez
thank you very much Madam president
Mr betel welcome to the European
Parliament
you have come here to this house as a
representative of Luxembourg a country
that has always been at the Forefront of
European integration more than seven
decades after Luxembourg lay the
groundwork for Benelux our European
Union faces sea change one of the
biggest changes in its history Mr betel
as you said in your speech the time has
come to decide how we want to continue
building Europe and I'm going to add
something to that also we have to decide
with whom we want to continue building
Europe the latest events that have
unfolded have shown us that we're at a
moment when some are shifting away from
moderation and are going towards hate
policies against women scientists LG TBI
and others and this is jeopardizing what
we have achieved in Mrs Meloni in Italy
is clamping down down on the rights of
lgbti people when it comes to the
registration of children of same-sex
couples
and is also trying to take away any
protection of immigrants there's another
huge challenge
climate change
the partido popular and Vox from the far
right in Spain are jeopardizing the
future of the juvenile crown the donana
national park and the vice president of
my region Castilian Leon says that we
should leave children in peace and that
they will decide when they become adults
whether CO2 is pollutant or not so that
is why we have to decide on which side
of History we want to be ladies and
gentlemen when it comes to the War uh
waged by Putin in Ukraine people are
trying to have a get a decent job make
ends meet make sure their children get a
decent occasion they can buy a house but
at the same time there are more and more
millionaires how can we ask citizens to
resist if they these companies aren't
paying taxes so Mr Patel we need to
commit to a fair tax policy social
Democrats know which way they're heading
we want to come up with answers to these
huge challenges we want to protect the
rule of law in order to make sure that
minorities aren't attacked the time has
come to commit to these causes I'd like
to thank those who
help me
write these wonderful speeches and at
the end I was going to say which side do
you want to be but having heard your
speech I don't need to ask you this
question so I'm going to thank you very
much for your commitment thank you very
much for being committed to building a
more social fair and more egalitarian
Europe thank you very much next is the
president of the renew group Stefan
seizure for two minutes
thank you very much president
it is a genuine pleasure to be able to
welcome the prime minister of Luxembourg
Bethel to our hemicycle for a number of
years now it is absolutely the case that
you have been in the Forefront of our
quest to build Europe and certainly in
relation to your size you have
contributed a disproportionately large
amount to our structures to our work to
our achievements and there are many
steps which we wouldn't have achieved
even yet without your input
I'd like to say prime minister that you
personally have remained absolutely true
to this historic Legacy of your country
which you've defended in the council
very robustly and as you've said before
the European Parliament both previously
and today you continue to
take forward these objectives we stand
with you we feel that conditionality the
defense of the rule of law the green
deal European sovereignty are of
Paramount importance all these points
you've raised with us this morning
therefore we stand with you
and indeed a large number of colleagues
right across the hemicycle would join
with you and myself in denouncing Victor
orban's populist Tendencies and
statements and actions it is vital that
liberal democracies stand together and
stand up for what we believe European
Union is the cradle and the key of
liberal democracy it may have
imperfections we're well aware of that
but in terms of decision making and
standing up for individuals this is the
way we wish to move forward and this is
clear from the way the council operates
Europe has shown that it can be flexible
and this is important you've talked
about the Constitutional approach to the
structures that we've faced we've had
economic crisis covid the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and we've stood
together with determination and resolve
both within the Parliament and in other
institutions and our solidarity has
established a very
strong robust basis for our action of
course the economic geopolitical and
climate challenges are there on the very
immediate Horizon and we need to address
those two
I shall conclude in just a moment
um Madam president of course we are
moving towards the elections
transnational lists are an important
consideration the right of initiative
for the parliament is very important and
I know prime minister that you're taking
forward these principles of ours thank
you very much for standing up for your
values and through that through many of
ours and I know that you can count on
that we can count on you on taking
forward what the developments we need to
see in the European institutional
structure thank you for president of the
green group Philip Lamberts
and welcome
I'm very moved
because I have a soft spot for the grand
duchy of Luxembourg
in my previous life
for 10 years I was a business
rep and my main partner was in Kolmar
Berg you probably can
a guess and I was seen as a Belgian
no it wasn't the Grand Duke just next
door but it's a real pleasure it's a
real pleasure to have you here
and to hear this triple plea first of
all for the EU for small countries such
as ours it's obvious that sovereignty in
the 21st century can only be built
together but as your predecessor said
and he then
became president of the commission Mr
juncker there are two kinds of countries
small countries and then those countries
that haven't realized yet that they are
small
so that is why I'm very pleased that you
the union and unity prevailed over the
pandemic and the war this is what makes
us strong but this Union isn't any Union
as you said this is a union based on
values I will never forget the compass
that Article 2 of the treaties is it
lists the values that underpin the EU
starting with respecting human dignity
not the Dignity of European citizens but
human dignity it doesn't matter what
gender sexual serientation beliefs a
human being is a human being and has to
be respected and what you said in your
speech was particularly moving
I'm glad that I can count on you to
defend these values and the council it
shouldn't be something extraordinary but
I have seen that in the council this is
not shared unanimously so to have a
vital EU value champions in the council
play a key role there was also a plea
for climate transition if you look at
the 27 heads of state and government
who is really the champion of the green
deal who is a staunch proponent but
apart from you I can't really see who
else who really understands what a key
challenge this is and how important this
is for our future
our future because the planet might
become inhabitable and it's vital also
for our Economic Development so our two
political families are working together
in the Luxembourg government and I hope
this will continue let us hope that this
continues I'd like to thank you for
everything please continue don't give up
We Stand By Your Side because we defend
the same principles thank you
thank you very much I'm now going to
give the floor to the leader of the ECR
Mr Nicola procaccini
president
thank you very much president prime
minister
welcome
the wonderful castles of Luxembourg
bring to mind the history of our
continent
uh history which goes back thousands of
years and which created us civilization
which we are very proud of which we love
and which we're determined to preserve
I'm not saying anything new to you in
seeing this Luxembourg is famous for
many things it's also famous inter Ilia
for uh aggressive tax planning whereby
many companies simply can evade payment
of tax and this in turn generates unfair
competition within the borders of the
European Union I am convinced that if we
want to have
proper Economic Development and we want
to be able to develop our economy as we
wish we're going to have to diversify
from finance and manage taxes properly
of course Luxembourg also is home to
Schengen the place where the internal
borders of the European Union began to
be dismantled
and where free movement became a reality
but of course the Paradox today is that
internal circular freedom of movement is
not really as free as external movement
is and it is also true to say that we
have are putting up borders within our
Union in order to stop movement of
migrants from one country to another
within the European Union for example
France to Italy but at the cell same
time we're saying that we're leaving the
borders open to Illegal immigration
which means that the countries of first
arrival simply turning into huge refugee
camps
with vast flows of people coming in
many criticisms are leveled at the
countries of first arrival they're often
told that they're not sufficiently
welcoming that they are not dealing with
the immigrants in an appropriate way but
when an immigrant arrives if they are
actually stopped on a secondary border
they're simply returned on ceremoniously
to the country of departure and this is
absolutely hypocritical and we've been
denouncing this roundly for some time we
need to be much more focused but we need
to have a more Humane Approach at the
same time and the
conservatives
are aware of the importance of our
history and the history which brings us
together
and this is why we agree with so much
with the Luxembourg motor which is that
we want to remain that which we are
thank you all to the representative of
the ID group Harald williamskey for two
and a half minutes
thank you sir
thank you very much Madam president
ladies and gentlemen well
it's
uh difficult to come to the speaker's
Podium
when there has been a great deal of
Praise but the two major groups in this
house are stuck in a major problem
look at the social Democrats there's
uh they're uh
cash
suitcases found and being confiscated by
the police and then the other major
group the European People's Party the
European public prosecutor is totally
investigating the coronavirus vaccine
procurement
so it's time for a little bit of
reflection to think about ourselves
let's try and not uh just try and laugh
this off when there are important
decisions to be taken we have to try and
take the right path but in every single
case we've taken the wrong turning it
went back started in like 2016 when the
British said thanks but no thanks we're
going
that's when you should have started
giving more competencies to the member
states
you should have treated them with
respect and dignity when they decided to
leave and that is something that we fail
to do same happened with the migration
crisis in 2015 which to date
has still not been done correctly we've
been taking the wrong decisions not just
labor market problems social problems uh
migration problems these are not the
only problems that are facing our
continent we Face Terror and crime on
this continent
ladies and gentlemen I'll remind you
Brussels the capital of Europe
where there were explosions at the
airport more than 30 died there in
Strasbourg at the Christmas Market a
couple of years ago
that was an islamist attack
same in Paris and the power bataclan
attacks can't remember these attacks
draw the right conclusions from the
mistaken policies of the past and on the
coronavirus crisis
you simply borrowed the idea of a free
Europe when we went for policies of
lockdown bankruptcies psychic Pro
psychological problems in among our
population
and as we know now all of this was
totally unnecessary I can give you
plenty more examples
same on the issue of Ukraine and Russia
the wrong decisions
instead with
feeding this war in saber rattling so
now we're going to be eating insects is
that the next thing that's not what the
European Union is concentrating on I
give the floor now to miss man on Aubry
as co-president of the left group Miss
Aubry please come
your time is up
go ahead Miss Aubry
Mr Beto
I have something for you what is is
common between uh Tiger Woods Brad Pitt
the Anna Safari
the prince of Saudi Arabia Aldo
um and the Italian market and others
they have a great passion for your
country Luxembourg
um there are good things in your country
as you say
actually the reality is that
um
you see people domiciled here for
example
in the uh
General pair Road it's an ordinary
building that I'm showing you here in
that building you find
1810 companies
which just happened to share these
offices so could you tell her tell us by
what Miracle
um Luxembourg escapes the laws of
physics as you know the after all these
scandals you see find these companies
which are just letterbox companies and
the only role is to avoid tax evasion on
a major scale the reality Mr betel that
that you're the head of a tax Haven
at the heart of Europe
a organized robbery and nobody can or
wants to
control it you talk about Frontiers I
agree but when it talked about the money
of the rich or the multinationals
there's a one-way Street and in
Luxembourg it never ends
and it's pensions and social services
that suffer
uh
cuts are being made
and
and you don't try to recap them recoup
the money from tax evasion
you talk about a Europe and of
cooperation and solidarity
um
but
some of the the shells are as empty as
some of the companies that are that
reside in your country
thank you Chris Dear Mr Bethel you told
in your speech about rule of law in the
European Union but do I agree that the
rule of law toolbox recently introduced
is not working by my opinion just
disappearance of the resolutions of rule
of law
in Spain Malta and Greece in this
plenary is approval of this fact
we commemorate today is the appraisal in
Warsaw Ghetto my great parents were
thrown to Riga geta I'm from latria
and then killed
therefore for me a problem of big
concern is a growing number of political
prisoners in Baltic states in my state
led the series of Trials of 14
journalists has been started yesterday
last week Jose accused of violating of
sanctions EU sanctions and
facing up to four years in prison thank
you very much neighboring Lithuania ends
up another journalist is imprisoned for
six years the same happens in Estonia
okay thank you very much your time is up
thank you Miss Danica I give the floor
next to Paul or Angel for one and a half
minutes
dear president dear prime minister
commissioner
first let me thank you and congratulate
you for reinforcing the tradition of
Luxembourg Commissioners presidents of
commission and prime ministers in
fighting for rule of law
for human rights for the rights of
minorities
because I remember that even against the
first steps of wrongdoing of urban
Vivian reading was always with the red
alarm and not by chance younger was not
voted by Urban as president of the
commission and so this is Luxembourg is
always giving the example and you keep
this tradition and reinforce it then let
me say as a Portuguese that we
experience European Union before we we
were members because of the experience
of our citizens in Luxembourg they were
so well received
that this was the true European spirit
and then let me put a political question
because at some time at some moment you
said that peace could be obtained in
Ukraine if there was a meeting between
xinji pink and Biden
and I have to say that I'm quite
skeptical about this statement
and I'd like to know how do you envisage
a peace process when you try to design
these new formulation because I see with
President Lula now what he's saying and
these are not good news for us and not
good news for Brazilian external policy
so I'd like your comment on this thank
you Mr angel I give the floor next to
vice president Mark Angel for two
minutes
foreign
remember our shared time in Luxembourg
policies sometimes in the same Coalition
sometimes shared by the balance of power
and politics we always wanted to improve
people's lives thank you for being here
I'm proud that Luxembourg a Founder
member I was always proposed supported
the European project and has been in
favor of integration despite being small
prime minister solidarity rule of law
and fundamental values are more
important than ever in a changing world
I'm counting on you to continue to
defend our principles in Europe
elsewhere as you've always done the
European population deserves our full
solidarity in its fight against the
Russian aggressor and in defending our
values it is is essential as you said to
preserve European Unity on this issue
solidarity also requires a determined
fight against social inequality the
deepening of the social dimension in
Europe
which has been called for from this by
the citizens in the conference on the
future of Europe is this is crucial and
this exercise at the conference was an
excellent exercise where we had
thousands of citizens involved European
citizen the European solidarity is also
about tax questions I welcome the
reforms for put in place in the last
decade in Luxembourg in the EU I hope
that this will be maintained we should
extend our solidarity towards those who
are fleeing war and persecution my group
the s d is happy that Luxembourg
continues continues to defend a Humane
position in a debate where that where
the with the harsh tone in the council
is important to find an agreement on the
migration pact before the European
elections prime minister the EU has
ambitious objectives in terms of
fighting climate change digitalization
or defense and for that it has to be
renewed adapt his rules it's economic
and social governance redefine the the
framework of budget resource and if
necessary modified treaties I hope
Luxembourg will be prepared to maintain
an ambitious approach to the European
project the ran for two minutes
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam president I
allow me to start by quoting our friend
Philip lombair
I want to address a very warm clear
Morgan to you and your team
now
in a small country where we seem to have
a China USA conflict where we have a
10th geopolitical situation but a small
country has to find its place in a world
where
Firepower
and intimidation seemed to be uh the
uh common currency no a country isn't
virtuous just because it's small a
country isn't necessarily an example
because it doesn't have the means to
crush its neighbors
but a small country can be useful if not
very useful because it knows how to
catch at an early stage the existential
crisis
that can be faced by other countries
so a prime minister of a small country
knows what he's talking about when he
tries to convince others that are all
larger than his country why European
integration is indispensable
like his fellow citizens he feels the
need to unite to cooperate to mutualize
the Affairs of the 27 member states and
to alert Partners to the consequences of
their actions and the consequences of
non-europe
so European integration is that just an
answer to some of the problems no it is
the answer
Robert Schumann who was the uh the
foreign minister of a large country
spent his early years in my country
and we can thank the predecessors like
santer Yonka torn and Banner
they all understood in this privileged
manner
why it's important to have rights and
not just force
the balance of power
is one in which we need to call upon
those
who are larger so that we can speak with
a single voice outside Europe
[Applause]
dear prime minister
dear Xavier it's always a pleasure to
see you in the European Parliament
historically and today still Luxembourg
is at the heart of the European project
and we pay tribute to our role as one of
the three European capitals in our Union
of 27 even a small country like ours has
its place in the negotiations and can
change things
I'm of course proud of the commitment of
the Luxembourg government against
nuclear which as we agree is neither
green neither safe neither renewable so
thank you for giving your clear support
and the support of the energy minister
Claude dormos and against taxonomy
taxonomy
well let's talk about Finance as one of
the sites of the three largest European
financial markets we have a particular
responsibility to put in place the
ecological transition and promote social
justice also beyond the union that's why
I would like Luxembourg to play a
precursor role when it comes to due
diligence of companies is luxury bird
Luxembourg finally support
the financial sector being included in
this directive the direct directive is
rightly an opportunity for Luxembourg to
clear position itself clearly as a
leader in terms of truly sustainable
financing financing which respects human
rights and environmental concerns
for one minute
thank you very much uh president
prime minister Patel one of the founding
nations of the community
of course Europe is made of of its parts
and its parts cannot be sequestered by a
globalist agenda Europe is a space of
Liberty
protecting those that are vulnerable
protecting the rights of Europeans a
space of security not a place where
borders are violated Europe is that
effort to continually improve a living
conditions
uh protect and promote development and
not those particular policies which
mutilate uh the structure the crystal
that we have created uh looking at Italy
Hungary uh numerous other countries as
well which are trying to somehow protect
the con the European Union from the
entry of products illicit products as
well so we have to protect the freedoms
the fundamental Liberties of all
citizens and that is our main task and
we are guardians of that
prime minister
the migrant crisis is
is again out of control we can see women
men and children drowning in the
Mediterranean every day we can see time
and again that a human Smugglers and
death spots in Turkey in North Africa
advocating richer and richer and we can
see that the cultural impact on the
European continent to so many welfare
migrants and most of them coming to
Europe are if we look at the Asylum
rights
the impact on the European populations
on cohesion and our sense of community
so in the Danish but people's party and
the ID group we've had a solution which
solves the problem as you know the
Australian model
where they have a pushback and Asylum
procedures are dealt with in three third
countries that would deal with
criminality illegal immigration and the
cultural impact it has on the European
continent we are happy in the Danish
people's party that the Danish
government
which have good colleagues like the the
social Democrats the venster and others
in renew are in favor of bringing in a
sort of Australian model in Europe
so we also hope that the Danish
government's proposal will advance in
Council we know how hopeless this
Parliament is when it comes to tackling
the true problems
when it comes to the challenges of
migration
the the weakest migrants those who don't
have can't afford human Smugglers who
can't get through the desert those who
really need our protection we leave them
behind in the camps but these strong
people those who have funds those who
help uh human Smugglers with their
terrible business model they get access
to Europe I hope that Luxembourg will
wake up and to follow the Danish example
the flown out to mark for one and a half
minutes
prime minister welcome good morning
we belong to different political parties
well I defend A working class you're on
the side of tax evasion and the bankers
but I think you have taught the European
commission and some of my colleagues a
good lesson and I'd like to thank you
for that
the European commission has talked about
banning tick tock
Tick Tock collects data well no doubt
about that I've got no trust in that
particular multinational Google and
Facebook are much better
I bought some shoes uh the other day and
I ended up with my news thread full of
adverts for new shoes
but the commission is not calling for
Facebook and Google to be banned
when the commission is uh trying to ban
Tick Tock they're being the United
States young people prefer Tick Tock to
Facebook and all the others
the US would like us to only use
American products they would like us to
only consume American News to make it
completely dependent upon them
from a perspective of European strategic
autonomy services like this have no
place
well the commission is saying you're not
going to ban Tick Tock just because it's
Chinese no we need to protect our data
on all fronts
so
I mean we don't need uh Facebook to know
exactly who's connected to Wi-Fi
is
Luxembourg is
is one of the founding countries of the
European community
and it is of course it is an honor to be
with Luxembourg together in this
particular structure
but
when
from one of the founding countries
comes forth and when there is talk about
Haze hate and about defining identities
through your particular identity
and filtering everything from your
through your convictions and calling
hate speech certain things that you
define simply as such that is
unacceptable I think it's very important
for children to be protected and that is
why we have this particular piece of
legislation in P in place concerning the
dissemination of homosexuality because
it is to protect children
Luxembourg may be the most
euro-optimistic European state but after
the unjust Schengen December decision
Romania is the most Europe pessimistic
after being in the ranked first five
most used most Euro optimistic States we
can only expect concern to grow in
Bucharest
Romanians have been treating like a
second class European people after being
handed out much lower agricultural
subsidies
this is only an example that list is
long
um
I believe negotiations are happening
behind closed doors over the heads of
European citizens in football this is
called match fixing who decides over
Europeans heads and in their names that
changan legislation must be blatantly
ignored if these were Germany or France
or the Netherlands or Austria would the
situation be the same well Romania is
not a second class country and it is
coping with flying colors with the Putin
triggered geostrategic crisis
Ukrainian refugees found shelter in
Romania before money being unlocked from
um from the EU Romania is moldova's main
partner helping it to withstand Putin's
blackmail we have to realize that Moscow
is applying the dividai tempura
principle principle if we don't
understand that the price tag will be
will be high
the European institution must treat
citizens equally they do not do that I
hear talks about a joint policies there
are fences being put up inside the EU
and remain in Transporters have to queue
to pass Schengen borders but they'll say
the European Union is only
strong if it is United but
[Music]
um
this ship is about to become a shipwreck
Ed prime minister battle
well it was good to hear your speech a
year before the elections to the
European Parliament
you don't fall into the traps of the
populists
they're talking about self-reflection
but some some of the people in this room
don't know how to spell it
I mean
we
uh did respond to covert by closing
borders and jointly procuring vaccines
but that allowed us to
succeed in the long term and we'll be
better prepared for next time around
we shouldn't be afraid of citizens of
course I you said that and I thought
that was right we had the conference on
the future of Europe I don't think
anyone's afraid of the proposals of the
citizens quite the contrary we're in the
process of implementing those proposals
but I think that in the council
we need to dispel the fears of the
citizens ideas we need a new convention
to strengthen the heart of democracy
what's your assessment
do you think we can get a majority for
it two minutes
thank you more I'm president as I
promised I will stick to my two minutes
and prime minister great to be here with
you and to discuss Europe's issues and I
want to thank you for your great
leadership uh finally we have the
opportunity to speak in front of the
full planner in a couple of minutes uh
and to hear your final conclusions uh
the think tank of the Liberals overview
this month is titled facing uh perm
crisis to remain the same the EU needs
to change I couldn't agree more this
impact of the coronavirus inflation
crisis energy crisis certainly the war
in Ukraine only those events in the last
three years are enough to shake up our
perceptions of Europe tomorrow let me
start by uh by uh thanking you on your
leadership on migration you spoke and
learned about migration after years of
deliberation compromises drafting we
need to make sure that we finally we
finally have a place where clear fair
and Humane rules of migration
are in place for You're Building higher
walls only provides a false sense of
security another extremely important and
one coating segment that finally needs
to find resolution is achieving full
integration of Europe better integrated
single Market capable to resist the
competitive uh distractions strong and
incompleted Eurozone but most
importantly Schengen area we simply
cannot continue talking about equality
in the union if we don't have all the
member states uh part of Schengen area
and third necessary is to making a full
use of rule of War framework lastly we
cannot punish the countries aspiring to
join European Union for our need of
reforming its infrastructure Europe is
not complete without having Balkans and
Europe is not going to be complete
without having Ukraine together we can
move forward with our friends and
partners with allying to the Europe
and thank you again for taking
leadership on many of them thank you
thank you Mr cute now it's Rasmus
Andresen for one minute
prime minister in your last speech in
Parliament a few months ago you pointed
out
to us our common European historical
Heritage you
condemned fascism being normalized in
Europe actually today we have a
fundamental discussion in some member
states there are alliances of party
which have a fascist origin who forget
history and fight against democracy they
want a Europe of Nations
where only a few will profit and most
will lose they start with attacking
minorities in the media as we see in
Italy where rainbow science families are
being discriminated and they're
ridiculous laws being brought in and
reporters being put under pressure it
must be our joint Democratic job to
fight this so it's strange that
conservative and some Liberals are going
into alliances with these parties
thank you very much Nick tarczynski for
one minute
thank you madam president
this is very important debate about the
future of Europe
this is very important debate and I
cannot hear the answer for the very
fundamental question
what kind of future do you want for
Europe
Do you want to build on the foundation
of of the European history
on Greek philosophers Roman law
Christian culture or you want to
continue with your politics which led us
to no-go zones in Sweden
burning sovereigns of Paris
terrorist attack in Germany and Spain
so maybe you should focus
on Legacy of John Paul II
Copernicus
Chopin
maybe you should go back to the roots
before we're going to discuss the future
so maybe you should be like Poland
with lowest unemployment in European
Union thank you Mrs maybe you would like
to be number one as a safest place in
Europe so if you want to have a future
for Europe like Poland because Poland
yeah time is up next is for one minute
[Applause]
well president a prime minister
Madam president prime minister
well I must say that I have a lot of
respect for your speech you have you
spoke very freely there are crises
around the world these raised questions
as to how Europe should behave in terms
of foreign policy
the key issue is how should the EU be
structured to respond properly to these
crises
the reflexive answer
is more EU more centralization
and on almost
blind approach where we really have a
real politique as what we should be
aiming for realism and pragmatism
the EU is a sick giant that is losing
ground constantly no one takes it
seriously
Mrs Vonda lion realized I said Beijing
when she visited last week
yeah
and the German foreign minister who's
now making the country more and more
ridiculous has done pretty much the same
we need a pragmatic foreign policy we
have to put an end to trying to give
moral preaching to other countries you
the constant European arrogance
otherwise we are going to make ourselves
ridiculous at the international level Mr
ludgen for one minute
good morning prime minister Xavier
congratulations of being in defending
European values as Luxembourg does
and also defending minorities
but I think it's essential
that
you go for strategic economy autonomy
where a solid type for Europe food
energy defense especially three sectors
which are essential for
the developer of Europe as a whole
I listen to you prime minister I'm
I'm just disappointed you didn't talk
about agricultural policy how come we
can succeed in climate change without
talking about Farmers those who fight
every day to feed us I think is really
important that on top of our values we
defend every European that every
European thinks European is an
opportunity
and we've give all our support that's
where we should defend the European
Union
for a minute thank you prime minister
for being here with us so that uh the
European project is still relevant we
need to speak about the priorities of
people and one of the most important
priorities that we all talk about is the
priority to strengthen the social field
especially when we have
a higher prices we need to fight
poverty and also the the war in Ukraine
so it is important for us that the
principles of the European pillar of
social rights and the sdgs should guide
our reforms and Investments social
rights must have the same must be as
important as
macroeconomic and environmental targets
and they should have the common goal of
improving the well-being of our citizens
and I must also ask you what our
priorities should be at the moment as
Europeans also in the social field and
also uh in in the presence of our
commissioner responsible for social
matters thank you
I wanted to speak here because I would
like to thank you on the uh speech on
the 17th anniversary of the European
Parliament you give hope gave hope to a
lot of those who are tired of heating
hearing from European leaders speeches
which are standardized which they could
be written by the
um Infamous chat GTP GPT you underlined
the importance of respecting minorities
sexual and ethnic religious or political
political minorities for peace and the
future of Europe I've you know never
rarely heard such a conviction as you
had
I'm asking you to continue and use your
voice to point out to us as you said
that
peace and rights can't be taken for
granted and we should defend these every
day thank you floor next to Siegfried
for one minute
thank you madam president prime minister
Bethel thank you and many thanks to the
people of Luxembourg for being excellent
hosts to the European Parliament and to
many institutions of the European union
for more than 70 years the people of
Luxembourg have always been at the
Forefront of European integration and at
the Forefront of Defending European
values let us stick together in
defending Europe against extremism
against yoga's skepticism against
Division and against exclusion let us
fight together for European values for
our democracy for our institutions for
the values of the Free World and let me
say that defending our European way of
life requires efforts and sometimes it
also requires costs safety security and
defense is something important to my
political family to the European
people's party and we have to work on
this together this is why my plea to you
prime minister battle that Luxembourg
increases also its commitment to safety
security and to defend spending as we
have all agreed in NATO to
um to allocate two percent of our GDP to
defense the people of Ukraine are
fighting for the European way of life we
should also defend our security here in
Europe and at our borders thank you
thank you very much Mr Morrison benefit
[Applause]
thank you very much president prime
minister battle welcome back to the
European Parliament
your country Luxembourg has been Central
to the construction of European
integration
together with so many other countries we
have now become a major Union
but we need more courage from your
country and from others from government
from the council
the 8th and 9th of May
on Europe day hundreds of thousands of
people will be demonstrating here in
Strasbourg we'll be demonstrating
everywhere in Europe calling for a more
united more Federal Europe it's the
younger Generations that are calling for
faster decisions without vetoes on
social rights climate rights tax Justice
civil rights
institutional transformation in Europe
to make it stronger the conference on
the future of Europe has sketched out
the route to be followed we now need a
convention for the reform of the treaty
so that we can have genuine European
integration while respecting our
differences let's not place a veto on
the future of Europe citizens let's
listen to their demands for a more
united Europe the alternative is
nationalism and nationalism as we know
very well always leads to war Mr benef
says Lucas for last for one minute
[Applause]
I'd like to welcome you to the European
Parliament as a member of the European
Parliament from a small country from
Cyprus I would like to greet the leader
of another small country which has
provided so much to the European Union
what unifies us our principles and
values and we have to protect we are the
guardians of these values I come once
again from a small country and I'd like
to say that solidarity for us is
translated into something which means
basically our existence and nothing more
uh ours our existence is thanks to
solidarity and I'd like to thank all of
those who have supported us with the
Cyprus issue and with this very
difficult period of occupation we thank
the you and the position of your country
on this particular issue we don't want
to fight by ourselves but we have had to
fight by ourselves on many occasions and
we haven't been able to private some
sort of closure to this terrible Cyprus
situation once again a small countries
in the European Union when working
together can achieve that cohesion and
that strength which Europe is ever so
dependent on thank you very much I'm
about to take the floor Christoph Hansen
for one and a half minutes
thank you very much Madam president
prime minister it's a pleasure to see
you
for the third time
in a year in this plenary I think it's a
proof of the respect that you have for
our Institution
it's not necessarily the same respect
that have towards you and Luxembourg
policies that are shared country I
regret that because we're here to
discuss the future of the European Union
I think the European recovery plan has
been one of the biggest deepenings of
the 20th century 21st century my
question is what will be the next
step in uh even greater deepening which
will be the next deepening you see a
second question which is very important
for foreign policy and security policy
is the principle of unanimity which I
think is counter project
counterproductive what is your opinion
and what could be done to get rid of
this system of unanimity a third
question
having to do with you you were talking
about being close to Citizens if we talk
about citizens
there is a problem problem of
representativeness and democracy
we had the system of spitz and
kindergarten
that citizens are saying that they
supported what would be your position
next year if we come back to the uh
Spitz and candidate system would you
accept it back to the prime minister to
answer to the questions quite a lot of
them that have been made to you thank
you
madam president thank you very much I'd
like to thank all of the speakers who
have spoken in the debate
is still here is she there
because attacked my country but I can
remember a similar scenario a few years
ago from The Other Extreme I had a
similar attack from Mrs Le Pen Mr Le Pen
isn't here
Gave Me a Riddle well
I don't know I think uh he was repeated
Mrs Le Pen's arguments it's madame
and it's not just the discourse but it's
a question of her being absent so I will
send her my response in writing
well I've had quite a few questions
aimed to me so first of all
on tax transparency
I can tell you that in 2019 Luxembourg
ratified the bilateral convention we've
ratified the minimal taxation deal
we're part of the international tax
reform efforts Luxembourg is part of the
solution to the problem of tax evasion
and tax aggressive tax planning
for many years now we have no longer
been part of the problem so I think we
really did stress the changes that have
been made in Luxembourg
a couple of other questions
I'll start with what the later question
from Mrs de Lucia on agriculture well
we've got to stop thinking that the
economy the environment and agriculture
are three separate files no there are
huge economic opportunities from uh
Greening our environment
do you really think that the economy
Agriculture and the environment are
contradictions and
a mutually exclusive no we should see
these areas as partners not Rivals we
need to have a functioning agricultural
system we know that we need to change
our modes of production our consumers
also expect us to do our job they pay
attention to what lands on their plate
and they need to ensure that the price
is correct too price is important but
also quality
you can't say that farmers aren't doing
their job
it is a professional Group which is
suffering from climate change it's
climate change that makes their fields
less fertile so climate change and
farming has to be seen together
there have been a number of different
questions about what to do on the future
of Europe the conference on the future
of Europe
the commission is currently preparing
legislative changes and I think we need
to encourage them
personally I suggest this isn't the
moment in time to change the treaties
why do I say that's my personal view in
some countries you'll face referendums
we have to make progress we have to make
the right changes but to do it at this
moment in time the danger is that we
will prevent the kind of changes that we
want to see so
let's do what we can without changing
the treaties let's make the necessary
legislative proposals we've also heard
about transnationalists and Spitz in
Canada
well yes I think that it's a good idea
that you can have candidates from 27
different countries because I think it's
a bit of a shame when you have these
spitting candidates who are not uh
candidates who can actually vote for in
every European country so the parties
should have to agree there'll be a
single list that we present in every
country 27 candidates on it
so then you can choose who you want to
elect so there'll be a nationalist but
also a transnationalist with 27
different candidates and then we'd have
a chance to actually elect a spitz and
candidate
otherwise it's just going to be making
the little changes here and there and I
don't think it's going to be sufficient
as for cheaping jingping and uh Joe
Biden and the idea of them getting
together to talk about peace well there
are people dying every single day in
Ukraine every single day
the primary thing that would help
Ukraine is a ceasefire that's my
intimate conviction a ceasefire is the
key if we want to end this Bloodbath so
that
well okay yes I know I've been
criticized for it but at the very
beginning
I took up contact with the president
zielinski and tried to get in touch with
Putin as well I tried to see if there
was any opportunity to find a solution I
gave up when I saw that there was no
openness on the Russian side to find a
placeful solution to the conflict
and when I saw what happened in butcher
I had no longer had the necessary
respect to work with the Russian side
and find a solution that way but what
we've got now is we've got Russia on one
side and Ukraine on the other I'm
strongly on the Ukrainian side
and I'm pleased that across our
political part is that we're aware that
if we have democracy on this continent
it's because at the time of the second
world war there are other countries that
supported us
a lot of people in in the United States
did not know where my country was but
they are the countries that liberated us
from fascism
and if the Americans had not come we
would not be a democracy today
we cannot accept that a larger country
simply decides on the future of a
neighboring country
I think the the two people who have the
greatest amount of influence are the
ones who would be able to create a
ceasefire and that is the Chinese
president and President Biden I've said
it before and I'll say it again
that's the remainder in Bulgaria
Luxembourg has never been against the
remainder in Bulgaria I've never used
National politics to block access to
Schengen for any country
on foreign policy
well in our Coalition agreement in
Luxembourg
we do say that qualified majority voting
could be a solution for uh for European
foreign policy
well trade is also important to me
that's something that you also have on
the agenda
I'm not
asking uh to basically endorse positions
from around the house but
to say that one country is an example we
should follow that example well we have
to remember that Europe is 27 different
countries different values different
histories different public opinions
different religions different Origins
there is not a single mold we can't
force every country to be identical that
would be an end to diversity
[Applause]
thank you very very much dear colleagues
today the European Parliament marks the
80th anniversary of the Warsaw Ghetto
uprising
so I ask you now to view a short video
that commemorates the events of the 19th
of April 1943 in Warsaw
[Music]
we had already organized battle groups
we attacked the German columns that came
into the ghetto
they had to retreat that day
victory was ours
elves
uh
of us survived
the leader of the uprising and the whole
command had committed suicide to
we survived by escaping the ghetto
through the sewers
[Music]
we weren't stupid we knew very well what
we were up against
but it was a symbol
the symbol of resistance against fascism
against servitude
their colleagues
today we remember we remember the
X